[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to lockdown math today we
are going to be talking about logarithms
and kind of a back to the basic sort of
lesson the intent is for someone who
maybe is not familiar with logarithms
yet or who has seen some of the rules
but has been confused by them and as
always to kick things off I just want to
get a sense of where the audience is at
right now because I have a couple
suspicions but I think doing a live poll
to see where everyone is might be
helpful so if you can go to 3 B 1 B Co
/live which you can find the link in the
description and you can also just follow
the link that's up on screen here you'll
find a poll and at the moment it asks
what best describes your relationship
with logarithms a I've never heard about
them before we're never learned about
them before B I've learned about them
but sometimes get confused by all of the
properties see I understand them but
wouldn't know how to teach them and D I
understand them well and could
comfortably teach them to someone else
to make them understand well too so
we've got a good split this is good and
interesting like I said the intent for
this is to create a lesson that I can
point people to in the future if they're
just not comfortable with logarithms and
I want to be able to say oh here's a
place that you can go for how I think
you know how I think you could approach
it intuitively and for those who are in
the camps of let's say understanding it
but not knowing how to teach it I think
there's an interesting meta question
around logarithms because I was
scrolling around a couple teacher forums
before doing this particular lecture and
when people ask what is the hardest
topic to teach in high school math in
the sense that students seem to have
trouble with it the most logarithms is
one of the most commonly indicated
answers which is interesting and I can
guess maybe it's because there's a ton
of these properties that you end up
having to learn you know so if we skip
ahead of that where we're gonna go
you've got all these piles of rules that
just look like a bunch of algebra that
can be hard to remember and easy to kind
of mix things up in your head and I
think when people have you know
sort of nightmarish recollections of
what high school math was like and what
logarithms did for them it's often those
particular formulas coming to mind and
what I want to do today is try to talk
through one how to think about them but
also just on the meta level of if you're
teaching somebody algebra what are the
points worth emphasizing what's the way
to get it built in their intuitions so
let's go ahead and see how people are
answering on this one we've got a pretty
even split between three three possible
categories all right so the most common
viewer right now answered see that they
understand them but they wouldn't know
how to teach them the second most common
are those who said they understand them
well and they could comfortably teach
them so this is sort of revealing that
okay the existing audience on the
channel at the moment that's people who
are into math and they're going to be
pretty comfortable with logarithms and
then after that be people who are
confused by some of the properties and
then at the bottom people have never
learned about them now if you watching
are one of the people who answered a
that you've never learned about them or
that you're not comfortable keep in mind
this lecture is actually meant for you
so when we're doing some live quizzing
and we're gonna have an answer I'm here
and we're gonna have people you know
answering probably pretty quickly
probably correctly given that as you can
see most of them are coming in
comfortable with logarithms don't let
that be intimidating don't let that be
something that indicates you should be
answering quickly or you should
necessarily be getting the right answer
right so I think the most intuitive way
to think about logs if you're just going
to start off is to say at a very high
level logarithms are something that can
take in a power of 10 and it just spits
out the number of zeros at the end of
the number it does more than that as
we'll talk about but just at the very
high level this is getting a sense for
what they do
and I think it's pretty important
because what you're saying here is hey
look as we walk from one to ten to a
hundred to a thousand to ten thousand
each step were multiplying by ten the
output of the log the log of that value
just steps up in these increments of one
so you can think about this as saying
hmm when I plug in a number to the log
if that number happens to be a power of
10 I'm just counting the number of zeros
what's log of a thousand oh it has three
zeros on it what's log of a million I
would
six zeros on it it's the zero counting
function and I think you can get
yourself very far in terms of
understanding very various properties of
logarithms just by thinking in the back
of your mind okay when I plug in a power
of 10 it's a zero counting function i
plug in a billion how many zeros are at
the end of a billion and these numbers
are all very intuitive to us we see them
in the news we we anchor our intuitions
in terms of how many digits does a
number have and logarithms are just
capturing that idea and in fact
logarithms have been a particular
interest in the last couple of months
what's kind of interesting is if you
look at this Google Trends chart that's
just looking for logarithmic scale okay
people searching for the term
logarithmic scale you'll notice you know
there's kind of an ambient interest
sitting around in September of 2019 up
to forever of 2020 and for some reason
suddenly there is a strong interest in
understanding logarithmic scales from
the general public I wonder why that is
and we see this sitting around early
March or so and of course this is
because this is when the corona outrace
outbreak was really starting to kick
into high gear and everyone wanted to
understand exponential growth and a
common way that exponential growth is
plotted is with what's known as a
logarithmic scale so I actually made a
video about this and in it I was you
know creating some animations and wanted
to illustrate this idea of exponential
growth and the main idea here I'll go
ahead and skip back to a different
animation is if you're tracking the
numbers in this case this was the number
of recorded cases of kovat 19 outside of
mainland China in the months leading up
to March you could just track what the
absolute number is but the pattern that
you'll find is that as you go from one
day to the next you tend to be
increasing multiplicatively
it's a little bit like earlier we were
seeing the powers of 10 one step to the
next you're multiplying by some amount
the way that the virus was growing was
very similar from one day to the next
you're multiplying not quite by a
constant but in this case for this
sequence of days it was around 1.2 in
that region you're multiplying by
something so when you're plotting this
it ends up looking like this you know
classic exponential curve that curves
upward and I can sometimes make it hard
to see where it's going or what the
overall
pattern is so a common trick is to say
instead of looking at this y-axis that
increases linearly as in here I'm going
from 5k to 10k 10k to 15 K 15 K to 20 K
each step is additive we're adding five
thousand instead use a y-axis where each
step is multiplicative so you're going
from 10 to 100 100 to 1000 1000 to 10 10
thousand all of these are increases by
multiplying by 10 and what you could say
is the y-axis is now plotting not the
total number of cases but the logarithm
of the total number of cases and this
actually makes it kind of easier to see
on a plot if you wanted to project out
what that trend would do and you know
it's a little bit of a naive model to
say oh it's going to grow exactly
exponentially but in the early phases of
something like this that is what it is
so I kind of fast forward in the
animation I made for that video and
what's interesting is if back then I
think I posted it on March 6th if you
just found a line of best fit and you
stretched it out and you said when is
that line going to cross a million which
because the y-axis is growing but with
multiplicative steps each time that you
step up you're multiplying by 10 so even
if it might seem like the 20,000 cases
or so that it was back then is very far
from a million you know when you're
understand logarithmic scales it
actually didn't seem that far it was
only 30 days away
if you naively just drew out that line
and in fact fast forward to around April
5th which is when that would have
predicted we hit a million cases outside
China that's pretty much the day that it
happened
I think plus or minus a day but I don't
remember exactly but it was right in
that neighborhood because I remember
thinking wow it was kind of a naive
model for the video to even use and it's
shocking that it matched so exactly
thankfully since then the growth has
stopped being exponential so if you look
at it on a logarithmic plot instead of
going up in a straight line that starts
to taper off but point being anytime
that you're coming across something in
nature or even in a man-made construct
where what's natural to think about are
multiplicative increases logarithms come
in to help you so let's go ahead and
think about what these actually are how
are they defined okay
and actually there was a question asked
on Twitter right before we started that
I think hits this very perfectly so max
182 asks us additions inverse is
subtraction multiplication inverse is
division but I never truly understood if
exponentiations inverse was n through
ting or logarithms if either one could
be you know if either one could really
be called that way can they that is such
a fantastic question max and I think it
comes down to the fact that with
addition and multiplication you're not
or I'll just draw it out for you
actually this is gonna be easiest if we
have some kind of exponential
relationship let's say 10 to the power 3
is equal to 1000 there's three different
numbers at play here we're showing a
relationship between the 10 the 3 and
the 1,000 and aside from writing it with
an exponent there's two other ways we
could write that same relationship we
could also say that the cube root of
1,000 is equal to 10 this is asking a
thousand what number raised to the third
is equal to one thousand that's sort of
what the cube root is asking and another
way that you could raise the exact same
thing is to say the log base 10 of 1000
is equal to three okay three different
notations the same exact relationship a
while ago I made this video about an
alternate possible notation that would
Center in the idea that you think of
this relationship between the three
numbers with a triangle where you'd have
our 10 sitting down here the power
sitting at the top 10 to the third and
the thing they equal sitting to the
lower right and whenever you want to
talk about a function or an operation
between two of these numbers you
indicate which one of them you're
leaving out so to write 10 cubed we
would include the 10 on the lower left
the 3 on the upper right and then we
leave out that bottom one so this is
indicating that we're taking a power 10
10 cubed for that radical what you would
say is we know what's on the bottom
right something to some power equals a
thousand we even know what the power is
so
than cubed equals that thousand but the
thing we don't know is on the bottom
left that is the sense in which radicals
are an opposite of exponentiation where
if the thing you don't know instead of
being on that bottom right is on the
bottom left
but what logarithms are it's an inverse
in another sense because what it's
saying is in this triangle relationship
we know the base it's ten we know the
power that it should be a thousand but
the thing we don't know is what's in
that exponent so to answer your question
maybe even more briefly we could say
that 10 to the X the inverse of that the
inverse is the log base 10 you know of Y
of some other variable whereas if you're
taking X to the tenth some unknown
raised to a power the inverse of that is
going to be the tenth root of some other
value and on the triangle it's basically
asking which of the things do we
consider to be a variable so are you
considering that lower right to be a
variable quantity are you considering
that top to be a variable quantity and
what what is the unknown but I really
liked this idea of making explicit how
we have three totally different
notations for the same exact fact one of
them you're using relative positions of
the numbers one of them we introduced a
new symbol this radical and one of them
we introduced a new word log so these
three syntactically different ways to
communicate the same idea seemed wrong
and so I made this video about you know
an alternate possible notation and while
I don't necessarily think that oh we
should teach logarithms with this
triangle because convention is what it
is so it's better to start getting
people used to the usual expression what
I do like about it and starting off with
it is when you see and think about this
triangle it's really emphasizing that
what the log wants to be is that
exponent every time that you see log of
some value you should think in your mind
okay whatever this number is it really
wants to be an exponent it wants to be
an exponent and we'll see more of what
that means as we go on
okay so every time you see a log it
wants to be an exponent this value three
and more specifically it should be an
exponent sitting on top of whatever that
base is now in terms of convention for
the first part of this video I'm just
going to be using log without a base
written on it to be the shorthand for
log base 10 because log base 10 will be
the most intuitive thing out there you
should know that often in math the
convention instead is that log without
anything might mean log base E
there's also another notation for that
Ln for natural log we're going to talk
all about the natural log next time so
don't worry too much about that right
now
and there's also yet another convention
often if you're in a computer science
setting log without any added sugar to
indicate what it is defaults to meaning
log base two so this can sometimes be a
source of confusion but it basically
depends on what discipline you're in in
math not math math people really like a
base of e we'll see why next lecture in
I don't all say engineering but really
it's anything where you want good
intuition with our normal base ten
number system log means log base ten and
if you're curious often in computer
science settings log base two comes up
all the time so like I said in the back
of your mind if you're trying to think
of some of these properties just resting
on the idea that log counts the number
of zeros at the end of a number that can
get you a really far away so we're going
to start going through a couple of these
properties and I want to do this just
with a set of practiced examples so
we'll transition away from the pole and
this time to the first proper question
and the question asks you which of the
following is true a the log of a
thousand times s cubed C log of a
thousand times x equals three plus the
log of X D log of a thousand times x
equals three to the power of log of X
and E none of the above okay and
remember like I said earlier we should
fully expect that all of those people at
the beginning who said they understand
logs well they're going to be answering
immediately they're going to be
answering correctly
but if you're someone who doesn't don't
let that intimidate you when you're
looking at a problem like this one what
I would encourage you to do is just plug
in various powers of ten and think in
terms of the idea that the log function
counts the number of zeros so I'll give
you a little moment to think about that
[Music]
[Music]
great okay so I'll go ahead and grade it
and as always if that's faster than what
you're comfortable with know that it's
only because I want to proceed forward
with the lesson so in this case the
correct answer comes out to be log of a
thousand times X is the same as taking
three plus the log of X okay and now
let's think about that for a moment and
like I said when you're just getting
started with them I think the best thing
to do is just be comfortable plugging in
various numbers and the best numbers to
plug in are the ones that are already
powers of 10 so if you're asking
something like log of a thousand times X
well I don't know let's just plug in
something for X log of a thousand times
a hundred okay well we know how many
zeros are going to be in the final
answer here well a thousand times 100 is
a hundred thousand we already
intuitively have this idea that when we
multiply two powers of 10 we're just
taking the zeros the three zeros from
that thousand the two zeros from that
hundred and we're putting them next to
each other so it should be five total
zeros but if you really reflect not just
on how did the number turn out but why
did it turn out that way it was the
three zeros from that thousand plus the
two zeros from what that 100 which we
could also write by saying the number of
zeros in a thousand plus the number of
zeros in 100 so this idea that a
logarithm of the product of two things
is the sum of the logarithms of those
two things in the context of powers of
ten that's just communicating what's
already a super intuitive idea for a lot
of us if you take two powers of ten and
you multiply them you just take all of
their zeros and kind of cram them on to
each other so the way I've written
things out here it's actually indicative
of a slightly more general fact which is
going to be our very first property of
logarithms which is that if we take the
log of a times B it equals the log of a
plus the log of B and now anytime you
see one of these logarithm rules if you
find yourself you know squinting your
eyes or a little bit I'm confused by how
to remember it just plug in examples I'm
being redundant I'm saying this a lot
but it's because I think it's very easy
to forget once you're swamped in the
algebra itself and you're sitting on
some kind of test and it's just got a
lot of symbols to remind yourself you
our okay to just plug in some numbers
that's a fine thing to do and often it's
a great way to yield intuition so in
this case saying log of a times B and
breaking it apart we could just think oh
that log of a hundred times a thousand
which is five there's five zeros in it
breaks up in terms of the number of
zeros in each given part great wonderful
so carrying that intuition further let's
try another practice problem and again
if you know it great you'll be able to
answer it fine but maybe think not just
what is the answer but how would I
explain this answer to someone or how
would I try to get a student to come to
this answer on their own without me
having to tell them what the answer is
and so there's two potential audience
members there are those who are
interested in the lesson itself and then
those who are interested in the meta
lesson so a question asks again which of
the following is true a log of X to the
N is equal to n times log of X B log of
X to the N is equal to log of X to the
power n C log of X to the N is equal to
n plus log of X or D log of X to the N
is equal to log of n times log of X or
none of the above so again take a moment
to answer as people do answer we'll
start to see them roll in and if you are
struggling to think of where to even
start just plug in some powers of 10 and
see what intuition you might get from it
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
all right so it looks like just about
everybody is landing on one particular
answer hopefully it's the right answer
like I said all to be expected so let's
go ahead and see if our majority ended
up correct and they did so the correct
answer here is a which it looks like
4000 of you got congratulations
telling us that log of X to the power n
is equal to n times log of X so again
let's say that you're trying to teach
this to someone or if you're trying to
come to grips with what it means
yourself I think a fine place to start
is plugging something in and in this
case for log of X to the power n let's
just try it with a hundred to the power
three and you can try it with other ones
to see if the patterns you're doing
actually work but if you're thinking it
through not in terms of simply seeing
what the answer is but trying to think
of why the answer turned out that way
sometimes one example will do because a
hundred cubed we can think of that as
taking well that's three copies of 100
I'm taking three copies of 100 and when
I multiply all that out and I think of
log is counting the number of zeros when
we say oh it's going to be some number
that just has six zeros on it that's
what it means to take a hundred times
100 times 100 I can just think of
grouping all of those zeros together to
get a million so this number is going to
be six but if we think actually why was
it six not just that's the number of
zeros inside the million where that six
came from is that we had three copies of
that 100 and each of those 100 had two
different zeros see that way it's a more
general way you can think about it where
if instead of taking a hundred cubed we
were looking at a thousand cubed or a
thousand to the N or X to the power n
you can think that it's whatever that
value of n was the number of copies we
were multiplying in times the number of
well let's see it's not x times the
number of zeros they were in whatever we
substituted for X which in this case was
100 so if instead I had taken something
like log of 10,000 to the power n this
would be the same as taking n copies of
that thousand ten thousand counting the
number of zeros in each one of them we
for so it would be n times four and of
course the general property that most of
you correctly answered is that you have
this lovely little effect where when you
see the log of something raised to a
power that little power hops down in
front of it and you just have log of
what was on the inside now one of the
maybe most important implications of
that I don't know if you'd call it an
implication or if you'd call it every
statement of the definition if I'm
taking log and I'll just reinforce eyes
its base 10 of 10 to the power n we can
kind of think of that little n is
hopping down in front and becomes n
times the log base 10 of 10 which is of
course 1 this expression you can think
of as either counting the number of
zeros at the end or more generally it's
asking 10 to the what equals 10 and the
answer is simply 1 which is very
reassuring because another way that you
could go back and just read this
original expression is saying 10 to the
what equals 10 to the N oh well if the
answer is n okay now with every given
logarithm property that we have so in
this case we just found one log of X to
the power n involves that n hopping in
front there's always going to be a
mirror image exponential property and
that's another way that we can help to
get ourselves a little bit of intuition
for these so let me just cover up some
of the future properties we're going to
get to here try to hide where we're
going what we just found raising
something to the end that hops in front
this corresponds to the exponential
property that if I take 10 to the X and
raise that whole thing to the power n
that's the same as taking 10 to the N
times X and this corner just gets us to
another intuition that you might have
for logarithms which is they kind of
they're like exponentiation turned
inside out and here's what I mean by
that the things sitting on the inside of
the log if I'm taking log of a you
should be thinking of that as the whole
outer expression for something that's
exponential in this case the a the thing
on the inside corresponds to 10 to the X
the the output of the function
whereas the entire thing itself the log
of a corresponds to what's on the inside
over here just what's the what's the
exponent of the ten so wherever you see
a log expression here you should be
thinking that plays the role of an
exponent on the right side and every
time you see a exponential the entire 10
to the X expression the whole outer
component on the right side that
corresponds to something that's sitting
on the inside of one of the logs okay
and we saw this above right the idea
that when we're multiplying on the
inside that's adding on the outside well
if logs kind of turn Exponential's
inside out that's telling us that
multiplying on the outside multiplying
the outputs of the function is the same
as adding on the inside because each of
these logs like log a and log B is
playing the role of the X and the y in
the expression on the right okay so with
that let's keep playing let's just do a
couple more of these and see how many of
these properties that we can build up an
intuition for so this last one
very nice thinking of exponents hopping
down the next one is something that
might look a little bit weird to those
who are not necessarily familiar with
logarithms but again plug in some
numbers to gain some intuition for it
and we'll give it a little bit more a
moment to pull up which of the following
is true log base a of B is negative log
base B of a okay log base a of B is one
divided by log base B of a log base a of
B is one minus log base B of a log base
B of A is log base a of 1 divided by B
or none of the above so it's asking what
happens when we swap the base with
what's sitting inside of the logarithm
and I'll just give you a minute or two
to answer that
[Music]
[Music]
okay so it seems like answers have kind
of stabilized out there so let's go
ahead and grade things and in this case
the correct answer of the choices we
have comes out to be be that the log
base a of B involves taking one divided
by the log base B of a again let's think
this through both in terms of an example
and then in terms of a more poofy
systematic reason why it should be true
so if we're swapping our bases let's
just start off with our good old friend
log base 10 and let's plug in a nice
power of 10 like a thousand it's
counting the number of zeros we get
three so let's try swapping the bases
and see what this should mean log base a
thousand of 10 okay well what is this
asking right
maybe you can't think of drawing the
little triangle saying something like we
know a thousand to something is equal to
ten a thousand to the what equals ten
well if 10 cubed is a thousand that is
the same thing as saying ten is equal to
a thousand raised to the one-third doing
the inverse here involves the
multiplicative inverse of the exponent
and the way that pans out is that it
looks like 1 divided by 3 and that 3
corresponds to the log base 10 of a
thousand it's 1 divided by the log base
10 of a thousand so more generally you
might guess based on the single example
that when we swap the base with what's
on the inside
it corresponding it corresponds to
taking 1 divided by what's on the
outside there and again you can think
this through in terms of looking at the
corresponding exponential rule now what
happened to my lovely little log and
Exponential's wonderful so again let's
hide where some other thing
and the other properties that we'll get
to here and I'll keep it in the same
order I had it before here I was
thinking that having a pre-written could
keep me a little bit cleaner than usual
but maybe it just involves playing this
weird game of paper cutting shuffling
around and so what we just found log
base B of a if you swap those it's the
same as dividing by one what this
corresponds to often exponential land is
if you take B to some power and say that
that equals a that's the same statement
as saying that a to the inverse of that
power equals B again it's kind of
helpful to take a moment and think of
the logarithms as turning things inside
out the expression log base B of A is
playing the role of that X okay and the
expression log base a of B is playing
the role of whatever sits on top of the
a okay and then symmetrically the whole
expression B to the power X is playing
the role of the inside on the left it
plays the role of the a and the whole
expression a to the power of something
plays the role of what's sitting inside
the log base a there so you can see just
by plugging in some examples and by
corresponding it to the exponential
rules we can already think through three
different logarithm rules which if they
were just handed down as pieces of
algebra to be memorized you know you
could memorize them but it's very easy
for them to kind of slip out of your
head and it's also very easy to get
frustrated by the task at hand but you
might want to remind yourself that the
reason we care about these sorts of
things is understanding the rules of
logarithms helps us do math in contexts
where it's like a virus growing where
from one day to the next from one step
to the next things tend to grow
multiplicatively understanding the rules
of logarithms helps you to get a better
feel for that kind of stuff so before we
do a nice real-world example of what
that can look like let me just do one
more quiz question in this vein to ask
about properties of logarithms okay one
last one before we transition to a
little bit of a real-world example get
rid of what we had here
[Music]
and now which of the following is true
log of a plus B is the same as log of a
plus log of B log of a plus B is equal
to log of a times log of B log of a plus
B is equal to 1 divided by log of a plus
log of B or log of a plus B is equal to
1 divided by log of a times log of B or
none of the above
ah and now we don't have as much
consensus do we very interesting we've
got a horse race between two so I will
give you a moment to think this through
[Music]
[Music]
while people are answering actually I
have a little question for the audience
so you know I was just talking about how
we might think in terms of
multiplicative growth and that doesn't
just have to be powers of 10 we could
also do something like powers of 3 where
if you're going from 1 to 3 to 9 to 27
to 81 all of these we can say that the
log base 3 of these numbers just grows
in nice little steps so log base 3 of 1
3 to the what equals 1 they answer a 0
in general the log of 1 no matter the
base will be 0 log base 3 of 3 3 to the
1 equals 3 is 1
similarly log base 3 of 9 is 2 you might
wonder what my question is but it'll
help to draw all of these out and for my
own pleasure here let me just write out
one more log base 3 of 81 is 4 now
I've heard that ostensively if you ask a
child's let's say around like five or
six years old what number is halfway
between one and nine and you say what
number is halfway that their instincts
for how to answer are logarithmic
whereas our instincts tend to be more
linear so we often think 1 and 9 you've
got a bunch of evenly spaced numbers
between them 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and if you go
right halfway in between I'll land on 5
but if you're thinking in terms of
multiplicative growth where to get from
1 to 9 it's not a matter of adding a
bunch of things but you're growing by a
certain amount you grow by a factor of 3
then you grow by another factor of 3
supposedly a kid's natural instinct
lines up with saying 3 and supposedly
this also lines up with if you have
anthropologists studying societies that
haven't developed counting systems and
writing in the same way that modern
societies have they'll enter 3 for this
so my question for the audience if any
of you watching right now have access to
a small child let's say in the range of
5 years old see if you can go ask them
what number is halfway between 1 and 9
and if you can let us know on Twitter
what the what the child says what their
actual answer is because I I don't know
why I'm
a little bit skeptical of whether that
actually pans out in practice I
understand this is not a super
scientific way to do it asking people
watching a YouTube livestream to survey
their own children and then tweet the
answer but for my own sake it would be
interesting to see some kind of
validation there back to our question
this is the first one that doesn't seem
to have a huge consensus in one
direction let's go ahead and grade it to
see what the answer turns out to be
great okay so 2,400 have you correctly
answered that it's none of the above
okay the log of a plus B doesn't satisfy
any of these nice properties and in
general unless we're going to be working
with certain kinds of approximations
especially when the natural log comes
into play we might talk about this next
time adding the inputs of a logarithm is
actually a very weird sensation it's a
very weird thing to do and to get a
sense of that weirdness plugging some
powers of 10 all right if I ask you log
of a plus B what you might start
thinking is okay let me just plug in
some examples like ten thousand and one
hundred and I ask myself if I do this
zero counting function of what's in that
input how many zeros are in it but it's
weird because when we add 10,000 100
well we're no longer at a clean power of
10 and okay that's fine you know often
you're taking logarithms of things that
aren't clean powers of 10 but it becomes
very strange to ask how you express this
in terms of log of 100 which was 2 + log
of 10,000 which was 4 because if you
look at log of 10100 it's asking 10 to
the what is equal to 10,000 100 you
might say I don't know it's gonna be a
little above 4 because it's kind of
close to 10,000 so the best you might
guess here is oh this is gonna be
something that's kind of like the log of
10,000 but that just feels like a
coincidence based on the two numbers
that we happen to put in there's not a
nice systematic reason coming there so
maybe you guess oh the numbers a and B
are very different
it's kind of close to whatever the
maximum of them is but it's very bizarre
and most importantly for the sake of the
quiz if you just look at the options
that it's giving you if you try this out
with any particular numbers you'll find
that none of those actually work so all
is good sometimes you get something that
looks like it's gonna be a nice property
but it doesn't end up being a nice
property and I also think that's
important rather than just finding
yourself only working with the various
you know log of a times B or log of X to
the power n these things that have a
nice rule sometimes you're out in the
mathematical wild you're working on some
problem you have a logarithm expression
and it's adding things in the input and
you want to be able to have familiarity
with the fact that that's kind of weird
that you're not going to be able to
simplify but if you you know if you
hadn't thought about that before you
might wonder oh is there just some
formula that I haven't seen before
so with all of that let me go ahead and
take a couple questions from the
audience before we transition to a
different sort of example
so it looks like uma Sherma asks can can
the bass be zero that's an interesting
question okay can the base of a
logarithm be zero well in terms of our
triangle we might think of that as
saying you know zero to some kind of
power X is equal to some other value Y
all right
this is something that we could write
either by saying zero to the x equals y
or we could write the same thing by
saying log base zero of y is equal to x
0 to the what equals x now the issue
here is that 0 to anything ends up being
zero right so if we're just going to be
thinking of log base zero of Y for any
other input Y you know you want to input
something like 1 or 2 or pi anything you
might want you're asking the question
zero to the what is equal to 1 or 2 or
PI or whatever number you might have
there and there's just not going to be
an answer so at best
you could try to say oh yes log of 0
it's a perfectly valid function it's
only defined on the input 0 but even
then you'd have trouble trying to
finagle what you want there because
saying 0 to the y equals 0 it's like
anything anything applies to it so your
arm is going to be twisted behind your
back however you want to make that work
and it corresponds to the fact that the
exponential function with base 0 is
entirely 0 it doesn't it doesn't map
numbers in a nice one-to-one fashion on
to each other so that's a great question
can you have a log base 0 now back to
the idea of where these things come up
in the real world one one example I kind
of like is the Richter scale for
earthquakes
so the Richter scale gives us a
quantification for how strong an
earthquake is okay and it can be
anything from very small numbers up to
very large numbers like I think the
largest earthquake ever measured and
this is just a chart that comes from
Wikipedia was a 9.5 okay and to
appreciate just how insane that is it's
worth
looking at the relationship between what
these numbers mean and then something
like the equivalent amount of TNT some
sort of measure of how much energy there
is in it and then what we can try to do
here is see if we can get an expression
for the Richter scale number in terms of
the amount of energy and why logarithms
will be a natural way to describe this
so the key to focus on is as we're
taking steps forward how much do things
increase so for example if we go from
two well in this case it doesn't show us
where three is so maybe we think of
taking a step from two up to four which
is kind of like taking two steps what
does that do in terms of the amount of
energy well it looks like it takes us
from one metric ton of TNT which is I
guess a large bomb from World War two
and it takes us up to a kiloton a
thousand times as much okay which is a
small a small atom bomb so just two
steps on the Richter scale going from an
earthquake of magnitude two to an
earthquake of magnitude four takes us
from large bomb from World War two up to
the nuclear age so that is noteworthy
and the first clean step that we get is
going from four to five at least in
terms of what this chart is nicely
showing us and evidently a single step
up from four to five corresponds to
going from 1 kiloton to 32 kilotons and
that was everything that was a 4.0
versus an earthquake there was a 5.0
it's easy to think yeah 4 and 5 those
are pretty similar numbers but evidently
in terms of TNT amounts that corresponds
to multiplying by 32 to get from one to
the next and going from 2 to 4 was
evidently multiplying by about a
thousand okay and the only reason that's
bigger is because here our chart wasn't
showing what 3 was so we were taking two
steps and you can verify for yourself
that if you take a step of 32 and then
you multiply by another 32 that's
actually pretty close to a thousand so
the idea that additive steps on the
Richter number correspond to
multiplicative steps in the TNT seems to
suggest that something logarithmic is at
play here and it's a little interesting
to just keep going here and say how how
much does this grow partly
because of the the world phenomena it's
describing yes not a huge surprise that
as we take another step
it's multiplying by about 32 again but
raining that in to our intuitions that's
the difference between 32 kilotons a
small atom bomb and then one Megaton
which we might think of as not small
atom bomb Nagasaki atom bomb which I
guess is 32 of the Nagasaki atom bombs
for one Megaton that is evidently the
magnitude of the double screen flat
earthquake in Nevada USA in 1994 I
didn't know what that was
thanks for capilla in terms of
frequencies by the way I also looked
these up evidently ones that are less
than two those happen all the time
there's like 8,000 of those per day but
as soon as we're in the realm of atom
bombs things like 3.5 and for those
evidently also happen quite frequently
somewhere on the earth there's around
134 of those happening somewhere every
day who knew but as we get even more
intense into this five and six range
which you know we're well above the atom
bomb scale
now we're only merely at around two per
day and you know I'm sure that a
geologist can come in and explain why we
all shouldn't be super worried about the
fact that there's two atom bomb
equivalent disruptions to the Earth's
crust happening every day but presumably
it's particularly rare for those to be
concentrated on some some spot like a
city where lots of people live now just
verifying that our thought that each
step involves a growth of 32 let's look
at what the step from 6 up to 7 looks
like and here it's giving us a lots more
examples in between maybe giving the
illusion that that's a bigger step that
it actually is and indeed that's the
difference between one Megaton and 32
megatons
so that's multiplying by 32 one of the
things I found most interesting on this
chart by the way was look at how far we
have to go before we get to the largest
nuclear weapon that's ever actually been
tested this was height of the Cold War
the Tsar bomb that was 50 megatons and I
believe they actually had original plans
to have a 100-megaton bomb but talked
themselves down from that 50 megatons
we're talking start off at that 30
to kilotons of the Nagasaki bomb
multiplied by 32 to get a Megaton
multiplied by another 32 rights we're
talking about a thousand times the
strength of the world war two ending
explosion and you're still not at the 50
megatons of what humanity is capable of
and that is evidently you know the Java
earthquake of Indonesia so 7.0 is not
just a little bit bigger than 6.0 it's a
lot bigger and the point here of course
is just that when you have a scale
giving you multiplicative increases it's
worth appreciating that what looked like
small steps can actually be huge steps
in terms of the energy implied or the
absolute values implied here so it I
mean when we're thinking about the fact
that there was ever a 9.5 that actually
seems absurd given that it's only in the
7.0 range that we're talking about the
largest thermonuclear weapon ever put
out and this is indicative of one area
where logarithms tempt to come about
it's um when humans want to create a
scale for something that accounts vary
hugely wide variance in how big things
can be so in the case of size of
earthquakes you can have things from
what happens just all the time around
the earth the size of a lady right and
in order to have that in a way that
you're not just writing a whole bunch of
different digits in your numbers for one
case and a whole bunch of different a
smaller number of digits for your number
in another case it's nice to take
logarithms and then just put that on a
single scale that basically puts
squishes those numbers between zero and
ten you see something very similar going
on with the decibel scale for music that
one actually works a little bit
differently where every time you take a
step up of ten decibels that corresponds
to multiplying by ten so rather than a
step of one multiplying by ten it's a
step of ten that multiplies by ten so
that kind of makes the math of it a
little bit screwy but the idea is the
same that if you're listening to a sound
that's 50 decibels for 60 decibels it's
a lot quieter in terms of the energy
being transmitted and going from you
know what would it be 60 to 70 or 70 to
80 those steps you know from 60 up to 80
that involves multiplying the amount of
energy per square area by a factor of
100 so every time you see a logarithmic
scale know in your mind that that means
whatever it's referring to under the
hood grows by a huge amount
this is again why we saw a lot of
logarithmic scales used to describe the
corona virus outbreak so how might you
describe a relationship like this where
every time you grow the Richter scale
number by one you're multiplying by 32
well we could think in terms of a log
with base 32 I could say if I take the
log of I'm just going to call R the
number for the Richter scale I might
think of this as log base 32 and that's
going to correspond to no no no I'm
doing this wrong no that's not the thing
that's logged we take the log base 32 of
the big number of the the T&P number
something that was like you know one
Giga ton or one Megaton it's 1 million
tons the log base 32 that should
correspond to the Richter scale number
but there might be some kind of offset
so we might say that there's some kind
of constant s that we're adding to this
Richter scale number and this expression
is exactly the same excuse me for going
off the bottom there this expression is
exactly the same as saying 32 to the
power of some offset times our Richter
scale number which is the same as taking
no 32 to that offset which itself is
just some big constant times 32 to the
Richter scale number so you might think
of this as just being some constant
times 32 to the power of the number you
see so this way of writing it really
emphasizes the exponential growth of it
that if this is what corresponds to the
TMT amount that you see as you increase
that are step by step you're multiplying
by 32 but another way of communicating
the exact same fact is to take the log
base 32 of whatever that amount is all
right now the next thing I want to talk
about is how we don't always have to
worry about how to compute logs of
different bases and it's a little weird
here that we were talking about log base
32 I referenced earlier how
mathematicians really like to have
with base e computer scientists really
like to have a log with base 2 and it
turns out for computational purposes or
for also thinking about how these things
grow if you have one log if you're able
to compute one type of log whether
that's base 10 base to base e you can
compute pretty much anything else that
you want okay now to get our intuitions
in that direction let's turn back to our
quiz and go to the next question and I
believe that this question is the most I
don't know this is this is a half way
reasonable question this should be nice
this is just gonna get us prepared to
translate from base to contexts to base
ten context and it's also a good
intuition for understanding powers of
two to have in general the relationship
that it has with powers of ten because
it's this lovely kind of coincidence of
nature that these two sort of well
you'll you'll see what I mean they play
nicely with each other so a question
asks given the fact that two to the
tenth is 1024 1024 which is
approximately 1000 okay so you can if
you're being a little bit loose with
your numbers and you're just making
approximations to to the tenth basically
a thousand which of the following is
closest to being true log base two of 10
is approximately zero point three log
base 2 of 10 is approximately sorry log
base 10 of 2 is approximately zero point
three log base 2 of 10 is approximately
one third or log base 10 of 2 is
approximately one third in which of
these is closest to being true based on
the fact that 2 to the 10th is
essentially a thousand I'll give you a
little moment for that
interesting that we've got kind of a
split on this one so I'm wondering if
they're gonna be numerically pretty
similar or if they're gonna be
conceptually similar or if there's even
a difference between those two
[Music]
so since answers keep rolling in I'm
gonna give this give us a little bit
more time so anyone at home watching
hopefully you already have a pencil and
paper out to be noodling through these
yourself that is the spirit of the
lectures that we're doing if you don't
now is the time to take out a pencil and
paper and see if you can think this one
through and write it out some of the
problems that we're gonna build to here
definitely will require pencil and paper
so now is as good a time as any and if
you're watching this in the future even
if you can't participate in the live
poll I really do think it's a lot of fun
to kind of throw your own hat into the
mix even if it's not going to contribute
to one of the numbers that you see
growing on the screen give you a little
bit more time here as the answers seem
to continue rolling in
[Music]
you
[Music]
okay so I'll go ahead and grade it now
and let's see how people did on this one
so the correct answer is B which is that
the log base 10 of 2 is approximately
0.3 and it looks like 1850 of you
correctly got that so congratulations
but the close contender not at all a
unanimous decision here
looks like it was d which is that the
log base 10 of 2 is around 1/3 so that's
good they're very numerically similar
right that it's either 0.3 or around 1/3
which is 0.33 3 3 repeating but the
question was asking which one is closest
to being true and let's see how we can
think about this so it points out that
you have a power of 2 which is a
thousand 24 awfully close to a power of
10 about 10 cubed and the question is
how we can leverage this to understand
something like log base 2 of 10 or log
base 10 of 2 as we saw earlier those are
just the reciprocals of each other so
what does this mean if log base 2 of 10
is equal to X that's the same thing as
saying 2 to the X is equal to 10 right
it's asking us 2 to the what equals 10
so what we have here is an expression 10
cubed is approximately equal to 2 to the
10 so what I might write out is we know
that 2 to the 10th instead of writing it
as a 10 I'm going to write that 10 as 2
to the X where X is the number such that
2 to the X is approximately is equal to
10 so if that cubed is the same as 2 to
the 10th this is I'll just write out the
full details the same as saying 2 to the
3x is equal to 2 to the 10th and
exponentiation is a nice one-to-one
function so it's okay to just say
whatever's going on in the input if the
outputs are the same the inputs must
also be the same you can't do that with
every function people seem to think you
can do that with any function but you
just can't and what that means is that X
is about X is about 10 thirds okay which
good so
place two of ten is about ten thirds so
if we looked at our answers though
that's not actually any of the options
we've got various things asking log base
two of ten being around 0.3 or one-third
so it looks like instead we should try
to reexpress this as log base 10 of 2
and well-enough what we saw earlier is
that log base 2 of 10 we could also say
log base 10 of 2 is just 1 over that
amount 1 over X and you can see this
pretty easily by writing 2 is equal to
10 to the 1 over X if we're asking 10 to
the what equals 2 the answer is 1 over
what we just got there so log base 10 of
2 is 1 divided by this amount which is
3/10 which is 0.3 great so this is kind
of a nice constant to think about
because there's this wonderful pattern
that happens when we're looking at
powers of two so if I ask what is the
log base two of a thousand like we just
saw it's approximately the case that 2
to the power 10 is equal to a thousand
and because we're doing things in logs
I'm just gonna be writing it in that way
a log two of a thousand is approximately
10
similarly log base 2 of a million well
let's see if we have to multiply two by
itself about ten times to get to a
thousand we should have to multiply by
itself around 20 times to get up to a
million
and indeed log base two of a million is
approximately 20 it's a little bit
smaller but this is kind of a nice
approximation to have in your mind and
then similarly you'll see why I'm
writing out this as a pattern in just a
moment if we wanted to go up to a
billion saying how many times do I have
to multiply two by itself to get to a
billion this is about 30 and any
computer scientist out there who's
thought about you know just how much is
a kilobyte or a megabyte or a gigabyte
they'll be familiar with the idea that
powers of two are nice and close to
these powers of ten or more specifically
powers of a thousand now what I want to
do is just write all of the same things
log base 10 not not approximately equal
to this is actually equal to 3 log base
10 of a thousand sequel the 3 log base
10 will you tell me what's log base 10
of a million it's counting the number of
zeros it ends up being about 6 and log
base 10 of a billion counting the number
of zeros it ends up being nine now the
reason I wanted to write all of this out
it just emphasizes an interesting
pattern here which is we're just growing
by these increments right as we go from
a thousand to a million to a billion
with log base 2 we're stepping up by
steps of 10 but when we're playing the
same game with 10 we're stepping up by
these increments of 3 so there's this
nice relationship and in fact for all of
them to go from log base 2 to log base
10 it seems like we're just multiplying
by 0.3 so 10 times 0.3 is 320 we scale
down by that same amount 30 we scale
down by that same amount okay now this
is an intuition worth remembering if you
have your numbers described with one
base it's basically the same as
describing them with another base but
there's some rescaling constant okay now
the next question is going to start
getting us at that direction but it's
going to be framed in a way that just
looks like a whole pile of algebra and
again I will encourage you to plug in
numbers if you want to to gain a little
intuition for it so as our third to last
question this will be a long lecture we
have which of the following is true even
just a whole pile of various possible
ways to combine log base C of B times
log base C of a does that equal log base
B log base B of A and rather than me
reading them out to you I'll just let
you look through them plug in some
numbers I'll give you I'll give you a
meaningful time on this one because it's
not it's not obvious unless you're
already familiar with logarithms and
it's worth thinking through a little bit
[Music]
we have an outstanding question from the
audience which is does the bar length of
the pole use some kind of log function
and healthily it looks like Ben eater
has gone ahead and directly answered in
the form of the code involved where the
chart max is math dot is that raising
two to the power of a ceiling of a log
base two of the maximum attempt count
which I think is to say unraveling if
you're looking at the maximum number I'm
not I'm not great at Vanna whiting this
thing if you look at the maximum number
in our poll it's asking what's the log
base two of that so as it crosses
different powers of two then that
rescales it and yes yes is the answer
what a fantastically apropos question
thank you Karen all right so answers are
still rolling in and I think like I said
I just want to give you some more time
to think this too because it looks like
a big pile of algebra plug in some
numbers to see what seems to work well
and see which answer fits
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so even if you are still thinking
about it I'm gonna go ahead and grade it
here and then start talking about why
it's true and then also why we should
care why this is an operation that
actually tells us something so the
correct answer which it looks like
around 1700 of you got congratulations
is log base C of B times log base B of A
is equal to log base C of a great now
that's just a big ol pile of things why
would that be true how do we think about
it now
phase one like I said me we might plug
in an example but let's try to actually
think about why the example holds so let
me pull out we've got this as one more
of the log rules this is just repeating
the end look what the correct answer
turned out to be where we've got an
expression for hug base C of B log base
B of A and this ends up being log base C
of a it's gotten rid of the bees which
is kind of interesting so some examples
you might plug in here would be things
like let's use a different color that's
huge green instead of C I'm gonna go
ahead and plug in ten log base 10 of 100
which is kind of asking how many times
does 10 go into a not 100 in a
multiplicative sense how many times do I
multiply 10 by itself to get to 100
where the answer is 2 and then log of
100 of let's plug in another power of 10
it'll be nice if it's also a power of
100 so I'll do a million so this one is
asking ten to a hundred to the what
equals a million how many times do I
multiply a hundred by itself to get to a
million how many times does a hundred go
into a million phrasing the same thing
ten different ways now the claim is that
this is the same thing as taking log
base 10 of a million that if I ask how
many times does 10 go into 100 and how
many times does 100 go into a million
multiplying those should give me the
answer to how many times 10 goes into a
million now just checking the numbers
this certainly works
10 goes into a hundred two times 100
goes into a million three times in a
multiplicative sense in that 100 cubed
is equal to a million and indeed how
many times does 10 go into a million
well 6 now we can think of this property
in terms of the corresponding exponent
rule which is going to look a little bit
stranger but it's actually just saying
entirely the same thing so here we're if
we have a base of C in a base of B and
we're trying to relate those to each
other the whole statement is equal to
saying that um suppose the B to the X is
equal to a I've got some number B you
raise it to some number X and a equals a
suppose it's also the case that C to the
y equals B those two together are the
same as saying C to the X y equals a now
that's kind of a mouthful to say out
loud but if you plug in some numbers to
translate what all of that is really
saying in the context of the example we
just did saying if you can write a
hundred is 10 squared and if you can
write a million as 100 cubed well that
lets you write a million in terms of a
power of 10 yeah so sort of asking this
question how many times does one number
going to another but letting you layer
it on top of each other now if we
rearrange that expression we get what is
probably the second most important of
all of our log rules the most important
is this top one that when you multiply
the inputs you add the outputs but the
second most important which is known as
the change of base formula lets us write
that if you want the log base B of some
value a then for what did we see you
want it doesn't actually matter what log
you have in your pocket if you use that
other log and you take the log C of a
divided by the log C of B that gives you
log base B of a ok so just as an example
here what this would look like is let's
say I wanted to be able to compute log
base 100 of things I just really want to
it's not a button on my calculator but I
would love to be able to do it and I
want to do it in with an input like a
million well even if I don't have the
log base 100 button on my calculate
what I can do is say I'll use the log
base 10 button and evaluate what's on
the inside here which at least
positionally it's kind of above the 100
it has a higher altitude as we write it
so this can line up with the notation a
little bit that it sits on the numerator
and on the bottom I use the log base 10
button that's in my calculator on the
base on the 100 and then I can evaluate
both of those and will give me the
answer in this case it gets you 6
divided by 2 which will be 3 and if we
really just think through what this is
saying I know I've said it many
different times but it's a it's a
convoluted enough way to write things
but an intuitive enough fact that I
think just coming at it from a bunch of
different angles can be important
because like I said this is probably the
second most important log rule we're
asking how many times does 100 go into a
million in a multiplicative sense how
many times we multiply by itself but
division is asking that same question in
an additive sense if I say how many
times does the log of 100 go into the
log of a million that's what division
means it's saying how many times do I
add this bottom number to itself to get
to the top but anything additive in the
logarithm realm is the same as anything
multiplicative in terms of what's inside
the parentheses so both of the left-hand
side and the right-hand side are just
saying how many times does 100 go into a
million but going about that in
different ways so this is extremely nice
because it actually lets us compute
things next time we're going to talk all
about the natural logarithm which is log
base E often written Ln and turns out
this is much easier to compute there's
nice math behind it such that if you
want to come up with an algorithm that
your calculator can use it's actually a
lot easier to think of log base E of
numbers so anytime that you need to go
to some kind of calculator I don't know
let's say we popped over to something
like desmos always happy to have as a
friend and you wanted to compute log
base 10 of some number you know let's
say we're doing a log base 10 of 57 and
it looks like that's you know it should
make sense is between 1 and 2 because 57
was between 10 and 1
hundred what's going on under the hood
how is it actually figuring this out
it's gonna be use somewhere in there a
change of base formula which is going to
be that the natural log of 57 divided by
the natural log of 10 is the same thing
these are two different ways of writing
it so if you know one logarithm you know
all of the logarithms yeah and well
let's just use that fact to answer one
more of our quiz questions and this will
be the second to last quiz question so
thank you all for sticking it through I
think we will be I think you'll be
pleased by the last question because the
last question will actually be like a
fun problem solving puzzling thing and
it'll involve a lot of what we've used
up to this point kind of a culminating
thing so before that though just to make
sure that we've got the instincts of
change of base down what do we have use
the approximation that log base two of
ten is around ten thirds so using that
approximation which of the following is
approximately true log base two of X is
about ten thirds of log base 10 of X log
base two of X is log base ten of ten
thirds of X log base two of X is log
base 10 of X to the power 10 thirds or
log base two of X is ten thirds times
the log base 10 of X and finally none of
the above so we'll give you a moment to
think about that you might want to think
to the chart that we were drawing
earlier and thinking about log base two
and log base ten as we're looking at
powers of 1000 and how each of those
grows that can leverage some of the
intuition but I'll let you think about
it stop talking
you
while answers are rolling in it looks
like a number of people have been asking
on Twitter about basically how complex
numbers play into this so you know we've
got general asking what if the base is
imaginary
we've got Kalkan asking what about
complex bases since e to the X is
walking around the spiral wouldn't it
hit every complex number
well it won't hit every complex number
but your instinct that it's hitting
multiple things is pretty spot-on does
it make sense to talk about Logs with
imaginary numbers by Mitya so to all of
these questions it's actually a very
nuanced question this the short answer
is yes complex logarithms absolutely
exist but each one of them has multiple
different outputs so a good a good
analogy here is how if we have the
square root function if I ask something
like the square root of five you know we
have the convention that you always do
the positive amount but that doesn't
quite feel honest it feels like the
right answer is to specify that there's
two different outputs for the square
root function two solutions to x squared
equals 25 and this is actually true in
complex numbers as well one of the
things we talked about in a complex
number lecture was that you can take the
square root of I and you actually get
root 2 over 2 plus root 2 over 2 I but
that there's two solutions you can do
plus or minus this value and so you
could say that the square root function
isn't a function but it's a multivalued
function it always has two different
outputs
now something funky happens when we have
exponents at play so if you're just like
someone who hasn't seen this stuff don't
worry we talked about it in previous
lectures I'm obviously jumping around on
the complexity level a lot here where if
in lecture 5 I'm talking about like
Euler's formula with complex numbers and
compound interest and like how that
plays into physics and then lecture 6
we're back to the basics of logarithms I
acknowledge that might be a little bit
jarring to potential audience members
but just continuing on with the answer
if you note that e to the 2 pi times you
know some number times I
this basically walks you around a circle
so that the output will walk around a
circle and just keep repeating as n goes
from 0 up to 1 it'll walk around one
cycle and end up back where you started
as n goes from 1 to 2 you'll end up back
where you started so for example e to
the 0 sits here e to the I pi is at
negative 1 but e to the 2 pi is also at
1 same with e excuse me same with e to
the 4 pi i that also equals 1 so in
general if you wanted to ask something
like what is the log base e of 1 you
know the one hand we want to say the log
of log base anything of 1 should be 0
because anything to the power 0 equals
that 1 but if we're letting complex
numbers into the mix you would have to
honestly say well 2 pi is another pretty
good answer to this question because e
to the 2 pi also equals 1 and same with
4 pi and you could even go in the
negative direction and in general n
times pi sometimes 2 times I kind of
wrote that in a weird order for any
integer in feels like a valid answer to
this question so there's a couple of
ways that you can deal with that in math
and before we get back to our usual
lesson just on logarithm rules this is
interesting enough I kind of want to
pull it up let's see what if we have
complex logarithm wonderful let's zoom
out a little bit great so there's this
notion of what's called a Riemann
surface that's basically trying to
capture the idea that you have a
function with multiple outputs and
intuitively maybe you can understand
what it's getting at where the input
would be something on the XY plane and
the output there's just many different
output sitting there so when you have a
complex logarithm you have to account
for that but it's used it's actually a
very useful idea to do but it takes a
lot more nuance than than you might
expect
so with all of that hopefully that
helped at least partially answer some of
people's questions seem same by the way
with
rhythms with based negative numbers
because if you're asking like negative
one to the X and really noodling on what
that means it's it gets you into the
realm of complex numbers so you have to
deal with the same multiple output idea
now answers are rolling in more slowly
so this seems like a fine time to grade
things and the answer turns out to be
you rescale it if you want to go from
log base two of something to log base 10
of something it involves rescaling and
one way you could think about this is
with the change of base formula so let's
say we have let's get rid of our key
steps let's say you have log base 2 of X
but we want to write it in terms of log
base 10 we can write that as log base 10
of X divided by log base 10 of 2 saying
how many times 2 to go into X in a
multiplicative sense is the same as
saying how many times does the log of 2
go into the log of X in an additive
sense yeah and well what is 1 divided by
the log base 10 of 2 so we're going to
keep our log base 10 of X out here and
from what we found earlier we found that
log base 10 of 2 was approximately 3
tenths was approximately 0.3 so when we
divide by it that should give us 10
thirds okay and this lines up with what
we were looking at a little bit earlier
with powers of 1,000 let's see where was
it where was it great so when we're
converting from log base 10 of something
up to log base 2 you know here we were
thinking of multiplying the top by 0.3
to get to the bottom but you could also
think of multiplying by 10 thirds to get
to the top anytime you have log base 10
of some number you just rescale it and
you have log base 2 of that number and
the rescaling constant comes from the
log base 2 of 10 or vice versa log base
10 of 2 so that's change of base like I
said it's very important it´ll X you put
everything into a nice universal
language and that should be all of the
hint that you need for the last question
which is a challenge question on this
one so if anyone's been watching
and they've been like I know logarithms
I've got this completely down let me
pull up the last question which came up
on let's see it's not the AMC but it's
whatever the predecessor to the AMC was
I believe so it's you know it's gonna
involve a little cleverness and
manipulation we've got this long
sequence of fractions okay you take one
divided by the log base two of a hundred
factorial and remember hundred factorial
is 100 times 99 times 98 on the way all
the way down to one so one divided by
the log base two of that plus one
divided by the log base three of 100
factorial plus one divided by the log
base four of 100 factorial on and on and
on up until 1 divided by the log base
100 of a hundred factorial so this looks
rather intimidating right certainly
adding fractions is never fun adding a
hundred fractions seems even worse
dealing with a bunch of logs of
different bases seems like a pain and
the factorial is playing into this so
I'm just gonna give you you know given
that this is the wind down time I'm
going to give you two or three minutes
to start thinking about this and if you
don't get it it's totally fine we're
gonna walk through what the answer is
but I'm just gonna let people think
about this final challenge question
before we call it a day
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
so can I give you a little bit more time
on this one because it's definitely it's
definitely fun to work out and I think
if you know how to start then great but
if you don't know how to start just
letting yourself kind of work with a
couple of the different rules that we've
worked out before the change of base
comes into play if you'd like to use
that and just kind of keep manipulating
and if it feels like you're getting
something that's a little too messy see
if you come at it from a different angle
and because answers are rolling in a
little bit more slowly now what I'm
going to do is just start to describe
the explanation here and then come back
to grade it in just a moment here so the
expression that we have looks like I
just started writing it out while you
guys were working on it one divided by
log base two of 100 factorial plus one
divided by log base three of 100
factorial and before you even start the
fact the thing on the inside of the log
involves a big product of stuff should
actually feel good because logs like to
take in things that look like products
because of the most important property
that we have which is the idea that it
turns products into addition okay
so right away you know that you're
probably going to use that second thing
you notice is that it's uncomfortable to
have all of these different bases log
base two of something log base three of
something log base a hundred of
something so translating it all into the
common language should be helpful how
this change of base work well asking how
many times two to go into a hundred
factorial is the same as asking how many
times does the log of two divide into
the log of 100 factorial it doesn't even
matter what logarithm you use this log
could be base ten base e base two
doesn't matter this change of base
formula still holds now what that means
for our expression is instead of taking
one divided by log base two of a hundred
factorial I could write that as log of 2
divided by so let me draw a little
dividing line between what I'm doing
here log of 2 divided by log of a
hundred factorial okay and then
similarly log of 3
divided by
of 100 factorial so all I'm doing here
is taking the reciprocal so instead of
taking log of 100 factorial over log of
2 I've inverted it log of 2 over 100
factorial because that's what this
reciprocal is doing so with that as the
beginning I'm going to go ahead and just
grade this lock in the answers and see
how see how everyone's doing so it looks
like awesome around 1796 we always we
always draw a little bit north of
Ramanujan's number around 1,800 of you
answered that it's 1 which is correct
congratulations 70 of you answered 100
which we can maybe see where where that
our error would have come from those of
you that answered 0 that's interesting
it would imply that somehow you have
cancellation at play because these are
all positive numbers so thinking one of
them was negative so you could probably
gut-check against the idea that it would
be 0 41 of you want me to come up with a
number fun numerical fact about 69 but I
won't 28th of you said 2 and I think
yeah I think that's I think the
difference between 1 and 100 maybe would
be interesting to try to analyze but if
we go back to our answer I realize it
may be a little bit confused rewriting
our expression up on the top here as we
add all of these things and we can
continue up until log of 100 all divided
by log of 100 factorial the key is that
now all of the denominators are the same
so we can add the numerators and the
more plus sign is just going to equal
something that top is going to look like
log of 2 plus log of 3 plus on and on up
to log of 100 all divided by the log of
100 factorial and it seems like the only
little contention among those answering
the question is whether this should
simplify to be 1 or should it simplify
it to be a hundred and really the way we
can think about this is to just break
down that bottom part
in terms of what a factorial means I'll
go ahead and do this on a bottom part
since I didn't manage my paper real
estate very effectively here the log of
100 times 99 times 98 on and on times 2
times 1 is the same as adding all of
them and you can probably see this
mostly cancels out with the top the only
question you might have though is that
in the factorial can we keep multiplying
down until we get that one which doesn't
really make a difference but before you
think about it too much you might wonder
hang on you know on the bottom I'm
multiplying everything and I'm adding
this log of 1 but on the top from what
we found before I never saw that log of
1 does that make any difference and the
answer is no because log of 1 is saying
10 to the power of what equals 1 and the
answer is 0 so in fact taking the log of
100 factorial is the same as adding the
logs of all the numbers from 2 up to 100
and it simplifies down to 1 so to those
of you who got it congratulations to
those of you who feel like you maybe
have better intuitions for change of
base formula for the fact that
logarithms turn multiplication into
addition that's my hope in the next time
with this as a foundation of logarithms
that can be pointed back to what I would
love to talk about is what's known as
the natural logarithm log base E and try
to give an instinct for why that's
something that we care about ok why is
it that mathematicians just seem to
really love the number E sitting in the
base of their logarithms what does that
buy for them why does it show up in
nature so that will happen on Friday at
the same time as this lecture and I look
forward to seeing everyone there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]